I don't know why Jon's going out with  the high-school boy just like these  nervous creatures that jump slobber all  over you  [Music]  if it's between you and some poor  bastard whose wife you're gonna turn  into a widow you are going down hey they  said they were going to the Twin Cities  oh yeah yeah yeah is that useful to you  yeah yeah yeah power is when we have  every justification to kill and we don't  [Music]  I I'm funny how at me funny like I'm a  clown me of you you know I don't think I  will kiss you although you need kissing  badly that's what's wrong with you at  some point you got to decide for  yourself you can't let nobody make that  decision  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]